foreign ministers from NATO countries
are meeting here in Berlin for talks
dominated by the Russian invasion of
Ukraine ministers will also be
discussing proposals by Sweden and
Finland to join the defense Alliance
public opinion in the two Nordic
countries has shifted in favor of
joining following the Russian invasion
Russia has warned neighboring Finland
that becoming part of NATO would be a
mistake
NATO member turkey may also be against
Sweden and Finland membership it accuses
both countries of backing Kurdish
militants that it says are terrorists
for others in the alliance their
membership is a no-brainer DW's Terry
Schultz has this report
becoming a full member of NATO used to
be a line Finland and Sweden did not
intend to cross in Brussels that line is
actually a street with partner countries
on one side and NATO allies on the other
we meet finland's NATO Ambassador Klaus
corjonen at the building where his
mission is located for now after the
Russian aggression against Ukraine so
our security environment in in Europe
and also in northern Europe it it has
changed
uh it's now more insecure and I think
this this move to increase our
cooperation and become member of of NATO
is the right step the alliance has
always made clear to Finland and Sweden
there's a place for them here room for
more flags and some offices that could
use new tenants but as some of the most
wealthy well-equipped countries in
Europe these new Nordic members would
feel much more important gaps than those
Sweden Finland bring different assets to
Nato Finland
famously brings the ability to guard a
very long land border with Russia Sweden
brings a 500 Year Old Navy and the Navy
that is among the largest in the Baltic
Sea where we should remember NATO
doesn't have very many large navies
accepting the two countries should be a
no-brainer for NATO says former Finnish
prime minister Alexander stube the more
nature compatible than most NATO member
states themselves who take Finland as an
example we've always spent about two
percent of our GDP on uh military uh
expenditure we have reserves of 900 000
we can mobilize uh 280 000 quickly
during the war time we have uh 62 f-18s
just bought 64
f-35s and indeed NATO Secretary General
Yen stoltenberg has said this would be a
record-fast accession process once the
two governments formally confirmed they
want to join though it will still take
months for 30 NATO governments stamps of
approval even ahead of their formal
applications Finland and Sweden are
receiving pledges from allies of
defensive backup against possible
Russian retaliation and they'll be
providing security as well I think
Finland is already protecting the
northern flank of the alliance and uh
with NATO membership that would be even
more effective maybe we have more
visibility and more information more
experience on what is going on and what
might happen so I think yes I think that
perspective will be welcome Mutual
Security is already a two-way street but
bound to be easier when all the Nordic
countries and NATO are on the same side
of it
but not all NATO members are Keen to let
the Scandinavian countries become part
of the defense Alliance
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
arriving in Berlin for NATO talks at the
time the alliance is seeing a sharp rise
in its geopolitical relevance
the talks are focused on long-term goals
but more immediately the accession of
Finland and Sweden are also on the table
not only issued Sweden and Finland join
NATO but they should do so quickly of
course I'll have a good conversation
with my counterpart it is important that
we have also consensus consensus could
be an issue native member turkey accuses
Sweden and Finland of harboring militant
Kurds Turkish people predominantly a big
majority of the Turkish people are
against the membership of those
countries who are supporting a pkk ypg
terrorist organization and they are
asking us to block this membership
Finland at least is confident this issue
can be smoothed out
Accord to my good colleague
foreign minister and a little bit to
take the tensions down and we will also
meet me today and I'm I'm sure that we
will find a solution to to this item
Unity is key in the alliance as it looks
to the Future in these Berlin talks how
to further reinforce NATO's presence in
Eastern Europe given the tensions with
Russia and for the first time to lay out
guidance on dealing with China
DW correspondent Alexander van Damen is
in Berlin following this meeting for us
Alexandra given those comments from the
Turkish foreign minister how difficult
is that pathway for Finland and Sweden
toward NATO membership
well we had a chance here to speak with
many foreign ministers and I have to say
that most of them were very optimistic
and and confident that turkey will come
around that they will not undermine the
alliances unity and will not eventually
block or keep they will drop their
opposition to Sweden and Finland joining
the alliance and some of them indicated
that turkey might have domestic reasons
or some bilateral issues with some
allies there are rumors that the reason
for turkey's objection could be could be
restrictions on weapons deliveries to
the country the us as we know also
imposed sanctions on Turkey after the
country decided to buy russian-made air
defense systems so all of this is sort
of on the table but we have to say that
most ministers here were very optimistic
that in the end the accession process
for Sweden and Finland should they
declare officially that they want to
join the alliance will be quick and
smooth
Vladimir Putin's nightmare has long been
NATO expansion how serious a Finland and
indeed NATO taking Russian threats of
retaliation to this move
well I think that any threats coming out
of Russia are being taken seriously by
NATO and of course by Finland as well as
we know as you just mentioned Russia has
vowed what they call military and
technically retaliation we know that
they are threatening to move more troops
towards their border with Finland which
is a very long 1300 kilometers that
could be cyber attacks
and they have already announced to
suspend deliveries of electricity to
Finland that is however something that
Finland can deal with they have a new
power a nuclear power plant they have
wind energy so they're not very
concerned about that and the thinking
here is also that you know Russia is
threatening to retaliate however Russia
have suffered huge losses in Ukraine and
actually their army is busy there
just briefly Alexander this landscape is
Shifting daily what else is on the
agenda while this meeting is going on
The Continuous support
NATO allies for Ukraine of course and
then they're also talking about a
long-term strategic concept for nature
that should address new challenges and
risks of course Russia's aggression but
also China's role on the international
stage
DW correspondent Alexander fundamen in
Berlin thanks so much